c'est la danse du hasard
j'ai une tronche de ballon une face de
montgolfière je vous jure que ça n'est
pas bon surtout quand arrive l'hiver les
copains sont obligés trop souvent de
m'attacher un arbre à cause du vent
sinon je m'envole c'est pas marrant puis
je vous jure pour draguer ça ne fait pas
mon bonheur juste au moment d'embrasser
je m'envole comme une fleur c'est
peut-être très romantique mais vraiment
quel malheur c'est beau l'amour
platonique et je voudrais jouer au
docteur
j'ai une ruine dans la tête qui m'écrase
le cerveau une pierre un squelette même
parfois un tombeau j'ai des dents dans
les pieds qui m'empêche de marcher et un
poil dans la main c'est la seule chose
que j'ai bien j'ai un trou dans le
tiroir une balle dans le four quand je
regarde mon grand miroir je vois trop
bien l'horizon j'ai les jambes en
compote et les profs fatigués les
souvenirs qui galopent sur mon crâne et
clavier
comptez ces pieds sur ses doigts il
paraît que c'est ridicule moi je suis
d'accord avec ça mais je suis pas fort
en calcul on m'appelle par un beau
malarmé ou Baudelaire mais plutôt Arthur
d'un veau arrière qui fils de Dagobert
devant moi ma culotte je sais bien là où
elle vit elle est la sur ma tête c'est
normal avec la pluie c'est pour ça que
je comprends pas tous ces gens de
partout vivre
et pourtant oui pour
quelle mise en scène pourtant moi
Mathilde je sais bien
sûr ma tête c'est normal il y a trop de
pluie c'est pour ça que je comprends pas
tous ces gens un peu partout il me
regarde les parois même parfois
je regarde passer les enfants et oui et
je m'en fous j'espère bien pour
longtemps
voici mes messages
c'est là dans ce diaza